for your movie 13 sins you were hired by
jason blum blum mouse ok productions
Bono's productions so where did you meet
him i met him in his office a few
everything right what how did the two
ends at let me let me go back if i had
the two of you come in contact with each
other I've got an email from my agent
that said jason blum would like to meet
you and then I went and met and he had
ten different projects because jason
blum blum is producing you know juggling
all these project at the same time and
he was basically just teaching first of
all he's this rock and roll personality
but have you ever made it I have no I
know he's amazing like you come boots on
the table and another the executives the
way I great I had very fun very high
energy and he pitched me all these
projects and I didn't really connect to
any of them and he created an atmosphere
that was loose enough and friendly and
warm enough that i felt i could say that
i could say i don't i'm not interested
in that story manila and when he was
done with those 10 he kind of talked
over my shoulder with her do you want to
show him 13 I turned around and realized
it was someone else sitting in the
corner but I hadn't seen before that
which was brian kavanagh jones who is
the producer asked turkington and they
gave me the original time movie 13 Game
of Death to watch and that was the end
of the meeting and then I watched 13
Game of Death I wasn't I loved the movie
but I wasn't too excited about making we
make no one ever wants to make a remake
necessary you know if they're saying
they do with it they're lying but I
couldn't at the time I was working with
Emma channel on the time on a on a
project and I I knew I had to do
something soon because there's this
pressure and Hollywood's but they will
all forget about you if you don't make
something within a year or something if
your career will be over so at least
that's what your agents tell you so I
knew I had to find a new project and I
just couldn't find material that I was
interested
and 13 sins or 13 Game of Death at the
time or something that I always had in
the back of my head and I liked the
material and the only thing that spoke
against it was that it was a remake and
then I thought if we can make this
different enough and naked our own and
not just you know shoot it shot by shot
then it's got the interesting projects
and so I said yes to that if I could
bring on board David Burke who had
written last exorcism or rewritten last
exorcism for me and with whom I was
riding with my shaman at the time it was
a complete genius who by now is writing
pother Evans new movie daniel espinosa
Smee new movie Robert Rodriguez's new
movie at he has completely blown up he
should be sitting here telling you about
his career Dudley but they let me bring
him on board and we wrote a new script
David wrote a new script which was raped
and what was fun about it is that the
structure of 13 sins kind of had this
episodic structure because there are 13
challenges that the protagonist goes
through so you could create a completely
new world for every one of these
challenges we're normally in a movie
there like one or two big set pieces of
the rest is just kind of connected
tissue here it was 13 set pieces yeah so
that was really enticing about the
material and then Jason Blum loved it
and then Bob Weinstein loved it and
bought it and then we went to enormous
to make the move that's a fee and this
story now feels very clean and if it was
just this Pleasant Road from A to B when
of course you know it was a one year
process of sweat and tears and blood not
between us but just in the movie making
process and the movie turned out
completely differently from what anyone
else thought I think better you know but
but that's what I'm talking about when
when people talk about the movie star
feels that was such a smooth journey it
never was a smooth journey it was always
an adventure and fascinating that would
do it again in a heartbeat but it was
never school you think that's why some
people don't come back because they
thought it was going to be one thing
whatever the movie is and it ends up
being not hearts of darkness type
triumphs that people are going through
you know Apocalypse Now or and in
dealing with all sorts of things from
opposition from the government things
like that but you know something work it
just wasn't what you thought you know
your ruminating late at night thinking
like no this can't happen and he thought
it was going to be where you heard birds
chirping and Brooks I have a friend
who's a very talented director who just
made her first movie and who said that's
a beautiful movie the outcome is
gorgeous name actors great and she said
I have no desire to ever do that again
she just what she said she could not
deal with the feeling of being the king
on a throne making the decisions that to
her what most other directors are
craving what you can get addicted to
yeah that is exactly what turned her off
she was like I don't want to have that
relationship with anyone ever like to
her as much as she was trying to build a
collaborative atmosphere on set I think
it could never be collaborative enough
she always had the feeling she was the
leader of something and she didn't want
to be bonita she wanted to be she's
amazing but I said yeah and I'd never
heard that from anyone but there was
that they had too much power on set and
that's why they wouldn't do another
movie but she is that person that makes
complete sense and she might not ever
make another movie I think maybe if she
gets over the experience and most people
have to forget the bad experiences to
make a movie again she kind of has to
forget the powerful experience of love
to do it again I don't know so I'm sure
that a lot of people don't make a second
movie because they are surprised by how
much hostility from the elements from
from every
they are bombarded with if they have to
get through I'm not sure where I'm going
with this but I'll just say it so
there's this book called quiet the power
of extra mertz Susan Cain introverts
introverts of i just also i just bought
did because i am an introvert my wife
isn't introverted and we're having a
daughter in a month and i'm like that
girl is gonna be the introverted of
introverts I better get that book is
active is it den it's excellent and she
does these case studies of going into
harvard business school she goes into
another religious college Tony Robbins
seminar and just how much in this
culture were were pushed to be these
gregarious larger-than-life personality
so just relating that back to your
friend wondering if maybe she felt the
pressure to be that and that's very
draining if you're an extra Eric you're
an introvert like you you you don't
always want to be on level ten but I
think people really resonate especially
in LA to that and probably other other
metropolitan cities listening to that
meaning that they are turn towards the
extra burden yeah they respond to and
whereas if you're too in the background
Oh they'd is everything okay are you
okay I think that is a completely
completely the case because I have that
in meetings but I think creativity and
storytelling in itself is a timid
process because you are trying stuff out
constantly you're throwing stuff against
the wall seeing if it sticks you're not
sure that you have to see it's kind of a
yeah but in a meeting with producers I
think we talked about that also four
years ago you have to pretend as if you
have it all figured out there is no
doubt in your mind you see the movie
clearly all like I don't know a
single creative person who has a vision
the Hitchcock claims that he basically
had shot the movie in his mind and maybe
I don't know I know that that's not the
case with me or anyone that I know but
for some reason there's this convention
that everyone has to pretend in those
first meetings that you have it all
figured out otherwise you won't get
hired which I understand from the
producer and executive side because of
course you'd rather hire someone
has the confidence and can take over and
you don't have to babysit that person
anymore like if I put on to display all
night insecurities that I have about
myself the creative process the project
the idea all that kind of stuff in that
meeting you know I would be a mess and
the producer with Celia and garlic I
don't want to deal with that stuff I'm
hiring someone to shield me from all
that stuff there so I think that is a
personality thing that a lot of friends
of mine that I went to film school with
that I think are the better directors
don't work because they can't make it
through that first meeting because they
can't fake the confidence in the short
meeting it's like an hour-long gift to
pretend they should almost be acting
class for directors to just act
confidently for an hour just get through
it somehow and pretend you know what
you're talking about because you don't
get at the beginning of the creative
process is that if you are meeting
someone and you're talking about the
plan to write a song you know that
doesn't exist yet there is no clear
fissionable you can talk about ideas you
can brainstorm you can talk about what
you don't want to do what you want to
avoid what you like you like the last
since you're a movie like the darkness
or their references but to pretend that
you have the product already made in
your mind I think it's kind of insanity
you